[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la bouche de mai est la reine du début
de l'été en particulier dès le mois de
juin l'émergent que je vous présente est
particulièrement efficace lorsque les
suivis magot viennent crever la surface
fixé dans les morts de l'étau un homme
santé mc sont enroulés la soie de
montage de l'oeil et à la courbure
aspire jointives éliminer le brun livre
fixer les cercles à la courbure
fixée en même temps le kill de pan et
barbe et teints en rouge ramener la soie
de montage à l'oeil est éliminé
l'excellent former un son corps régulier
avec l'asean montage
puis avec la rotation de l'étau enroulée
aspire jointives le kill de pan et barbe
et jusqu'à brouiller
fermement le tilt avec glaçons avantage
éliminer l'excédent
fixez les ailes en fait de long par des
enroulements de soi de montage en forme
de x
n'ayez pas peur pour cela de vous aider
de votre main libre coupez les excédents
apparaît un du bing synthétique
puis avec le du bit loupe réaliser une
boucle
vrille et la soie et le du bing ensemble
puis enroulez ledoux bing ainsi
réalisées de chaque côté désert en
formant des figurants knicks
c'est le du bing allié avec la soie de
montage
pelez le surplus
formé une haie géré tête
et finir la mouche avec le whif finish
éliminé de la soie de montage coupé
ensemble les deux ailes à la bonne
longueur
les remettent en position de spent la
mouche est maintenant terminée
les mouches de mai à fall détruites
cette imitation accords détachées est
particulièrement efficace lorsque le sib
imago dérive en surface fixe et un homme
sont yengo tmc 921 dans les mâchoires de
l'étau enroulé la soie de montage de
l'oeil et vers la courbure éliminer le
brun libre ramener la soie de montage au
milieu de la hampe est fixé ainsi man
tube body grande éphémère jaune olive
fermement avec la soie de montage
fait la soie préparer un dut bing de cul
de canard puis avec le turbo twister du
bing réaliser une boucle et former un du
bing très serré
avec la rotation de l'étau formé un
thorax réaliste
fixez le du bignot l'oeillet et éliminer
le surplus
présenté deux plumes de canard et les
fixer ensemble à l'oeil et ses plumes
représentant les ailes de l'insecte
éliminer les pieds inutile former une
petite tête à l'aide du wif finish finir
la mouche maintenant éliminer la soie de
montage
la mouche de mai est maintenant terminée
pour les pêcheurs qui sont assoiffés
d'entomologie il existe un grand nombre
d'ouvragés qui vont traiter ces
problèmes là et qu'ils vont pouvoir vous
apprendre tous ces détails pour ceux qui
vont vouloir être relativement simple
dans leur approche au niveau
d'entomologie suit les conseils des
guides suivez les conseils de tout ce
que vous pouvez prendre au bord de l'eau
et laissez vous faire par contre
travailler beaucoup plus sa technique
ce soit de toute manière pour un
entomologiste ou pour un monteur
amateurs et à pêcheurs amateurs de plus
important ce n'est pas d'avoir la
perfection niveau de la mouche mais
c'est toujours bien la présenter
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
ah ah